in the early days of deep learning
people used to worry a lot about the
optimization algorithm getting stuck in
bad local optima but as the theory of
deep learning has advanced our
understanding of local optima is also
changing let me show you how we now
think about local optima and problems in
the optimization problem in deep
learning so this was a picture people
used to have in mind when they worried
about local optima maybe you're trying
to optimize some set of parameters and
we call them W 1 and W 2 and the height
of the surface is the cost function so
in this picture it looks like there are
a lot of local optima you know in in all
those places and it'd be easy for
gradient descents or one of the other
algorithms to get stuck on a local
optimum rather than find this way to a
global optimum it turns out that if you
are plotting a figure like this in two
dimensions then it's easy to create
plots like this of a lot of different
local optima and these very low
dimensional plots used to gather
intuition but this intuition isn't
actually correct it turns out if you
create in your network most points of 0
gradients are not local optima like
points like this instead most points of
0 gradients in the cost function are
actually saddle points so that's a point
with a zero gradient again this is maybe
W 1 W 2 and the highest heightens the
value of the cost function J but
informally a function in a very high
dimensional space if the gradient is 0
then in each direction it can either be
a convex light function or a concave
light function and if you are in say a
20,000 dimensional space then thread to
be a local optima all 20,000 directions
need to look like this and so the chance
of that happening is maybe very small
you know maybe 2 to the minus 20000
instead you're much more likely to get
some directions where the curve bends up
like so as well some directions where
the function is bending down rather than
have them all Bend upwards so that's why
in very high dimensional spaces you're
actually much more likely to run into a
saddle points like that shown on the
right then
local optimum oh and as for why the
surface is called a saddle point if you
can picture maybe this is a sort of
shadow you put on a horse right so maybe
if this is a horse I guess there's a
head of a horse as you I have a horse
you know I guess and right well another
great drawing of a horse but you get the
idea then you the rider will sit here in
the saddle so then so that's why this
point here where the derivative is zero
that point is called a saddle point it's
really the point to understand where
you're sitting s and that happens to
have you know derivative zero and so one
of the lessons we learned in history of
deep learning is that a lot of our
intuitions about low dimensional spaces
like what you can plot on the left
they really don't transfer to the very
high dimensional spaces then our
learning algorithms are operating over
because if you have twenty thousand
parameters then J is V a function over a
twenty thousand dimensional vector and
you're much more likely to see saddle
points than local optimum if local
optima aren't a problem then what is a
problem it turns out that plateaus can
really slow down learning and the
plateau is a region where the derivative
is close to zero for a long time so if
you are here then gradient descent will
move down the surface and because the
gradient is zero or near zero the
surface is quite flat you can actually
take a very long time you know to slowly
find your way to maybe this point on the
plateau and then because of a random
perturbation to the left or right maybe
then finally I'm gonna switch pen colors
for clarity your algorithm can then find
this way off the plateau but then to
take this very long slope off before
it's found this way here and they could
get off this plateau
so the takeaways from this video are
first you actually pretty unlikely to
get stuck in bad local optima so long as
you're training and reasonably launched
new network save a lot of parameters and
the cost function J is defined over a
relatively high dimensional space but
second that plateaus are a problem and
they can actually make learning pretty
slow and this is where algorithms like
momentum or our most proper atom can
really help you learning algorithm as
well and these are scenarios where more
sophisticated optimization algorithms
such as atom can actually speed up the
rate at which you could move down the
plateau and then get off the plateau so
because your networks are solving
optimization problems over such high
dimensional spaces to be honest I don't
think anyone has great intuitions about
what these spaces really look like and
our understanding of them is still
evolving but I hope this gives you some
better intuition about the challenges
that the optimization algorithms may
face so that congratulations on coming
to the end of this week's content please
take a look at this week's quiz as well
as the exercise I hope you enjoyed
practicing some of these ideas with this
week's forum exercise and I look forward
to seeing you at the start of next
week's videos